I am Nicholas be with reasontv we're in
Las Vegas at Freedom Fest and right now
we're talking with janeil Schulman
author filmmaker most recently of Lady
Magdalene's with Nichelle Nichols and
also alongside night a novel of 1999
which is his next film project Neal
thanks for talking to us thank you okay
tell us about Lady Magdalene which
you're showing here what's the plot and
why should people watch it lady
Magdalene's is a trench and satire of
everything that's wrong with Homeland
Security starting off with the
traditional you know screening grandma
at airport security in the beginning and
by the time they're done they're hot on
the trail of al-qaeda thinking there's
going to be a bombing plot against super
damn but of course they have that wrong
and where does most of the action take
place in this movie most of the action
takes place in Nevada Pahrump Nevada
where which is one of the areas of
Nevada where you have legalized
prostitution legalized brothels and our
action does I really feel like you're
hiding the ball so that lady Magdalene's
refers to a house oppressed lady lady
Magdalene is a brothel in pahrump it is
the fictional third brothel in pahrump
what is the what's what's your basic
beef with Homeland Security they don't
trust the public they treat everybody in
the public as if we're the terrorists
you know it's like the the school
teacher who was you know says you know
if I can't find out who did it you're
all staying after school well that's how
Homeland Security does you know they
they basically treat us all as if we're
terrorists and just instead instead of
realizing that flight 93 united 93
showed us that in fact the private
civilians are the only ones on 911 who
actually stopped an al Qaeda attack
where is the best place to watch lady
Magdalene well the easiest place to do
is to go to amazon.com or we have it
both as instant video and as a DVD okay
great and then a long side night it's
your next film project it's based on one
of your novels tell us the plot and
where the movie is in terms of
production okay well first of all it's
not it's no longer a novel of 1999 back
when I first came out in 1979 it was
thought of as science
we've gone past the the 1999 window and
it's basically i like to call it the
novel of 1979 ripped from today's
headlines because it starts out with the
last two weeks of the United States
before hyperinflation causes the total
collapse the point in which they don't
have any money to pay the army anymore
and it's told from the point of view of
the 18 year old son of a world-famous
Nobel Prize a prize-winning libertarian
economist named Martin Vreeland yeah you
might sit you might remember the David
Friedman was one of my advisors on the
novel fact you know back in the day and
Milton Friedman did endorse the book so
I'm basically what happens is he runs
into the Revolutionary agarest cadre who
are offering a lifeboat solution to the
Titanic economy okay and when when is
the movie coming out where we intend to
be in principal photography by the end
of this year it says on IMDB that the
movie will be out in 2012 and that's
what I'm aiming for it okay well that's
great and it the novel is still
available right the novel is on
amazon.com but also the you know the
easiest way to get it is you go to ww a
long side night net we're already two
hundred and eighty-five thousand people
have downloaded the free pdf okay which
brings us to our final point this is an
incredible world to be a both a producer
and consumer of art and culture creative
expression more generally you know there
are just so many more ways to get to
make your stuff and to get it out there
and for people to access it how do you
feel about this new world of kind of
culture on demand well it's shifted the
emphasis it used to be that there was a
gatekeeper of getting distribution
distribution is is copiously easy to get
right now because you could just go on
the web and you could distribute
anything you want they're very few
barriers the problem is we're now going
for the problem of monetizing monetizing
what you're distributing and that's a
problem first of all publicity gaining
eyeballs and there's still money and
publicity and an advertising that has to
go into that and then you have to figure
out a way to create a revenue stream
going the other direction and I'm not
only competing making a movie with you
know a hundred-million-dollar production
of Green Hornet over 200 million dollar
production of avatar I'm also competing
with with the actress who goes on
YouTube cries about the fact
she loves cats on a date on a supposed
dating profile and gets 10 million hits
you know absolutely free so on the one
hand I've got you know multi you know
hundreds of million dollar productions
and I'm competing with on the other hand
I've got these multi-million hit three
productions that I'm dealing with and
I'm stuck in the middle trying to figure
out a way to monetize my investment I
have what's your strategy then the
strata the strategy is basically
targeted marketing in other words you
out you have to try an get triangulate
your markets figure out exactly who
you're who you're you know your market
is who you're trying to sell to and then
you basically hit them and try to give
them something they can't get from
either the free you know five-minute
production or the hundred million dollar
feature Neil what's the best place for
people to sample your wares well I'm the
easiest person on the internet to find
because I've got jennie-o Schulman calm
my personal website I blog on rational
review genial Schulman at rational
review you can't you can't miss me by
going to to IMDB or amazon.com or
Wikipedia they all have you know links
to me so uh and then of course you know
you go by title alongside nycom
alongside night net for the free
download alongside night movie com lady
magal INSCOM or amazon.com here keeping
godaddy in business for at least another
hey listen I just signed up for a
two-year discount on godaddy i'm using
them so much jaynell Schulman author
filmmaker thank you for talking to
recent TV my pleasure for a reason TV
I'm Nicholas